welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home's
rumored twist that past peter parker's
toby mcguire and andrew garfield could
appear as well is either the worst kept
secret or a [ __ ] belief willed into
reality by the wishful thinking of die
hards which now they think of it might
be the only way anything has come to be
considered true oh god andrew garfield
has repeatedly denied appearing in the
film in interviews that only seemed to
dig him in deeper with fans convinced he
is deceiving us but then the story
exploded this week when the biggest
rumored leak yet was discussed by jimmy
fallon on the tonight show and now
garfield's response and the validity of
that leak itself has gotten so muddy
that we need an explanation of not just
what we actually know about this movie's
plot and how vfx works but the inner
workings of media cycles and how shadowy
power players are actively manipulating
our expectations now before i continue
while the rumors of andrew garfield and
toby mcguire are very well known at this
point i understand if you feel a bit
weird about specific material that might
have been leaked you totally don't have
to continue watching i'm only interested
in breaking down the narrative around
the leak and how media might have been
manipulated and the publicity trickery
at work and how for many that has become
the bigger story here but in order to do
that i do have to show you what is out
there okay i covered the timeline of
this speculation train in an episode of
big question and at that point the
biggest update was andrew garfield's
denial to josh horowitz unhappy sad
confused like they might be doing
something
i ain't got a call so like i'm not the
werewolf i promise you i am not the
werewolf and everyone's like you're the
werewolf you're the werewolf look at him
he's like he's doing this
i did not get a call ever since then we
have now gotten a trailer for spider-man
no way home that confirms theories that
along with the previously announced
returns of alfred molina dock and jimmy
fox electro we will also see stuff that
we previously thought was just bs rumors
willem daffo green goblin among other
villains from past alt universe
spider-man titles add that to the clue
that we discussed that peter parker is
wearing the same outfit toby maguire
peter wore in sam raimi's spider-man 3
in 2007 which you could interpret as doc
ox hi peter recognition of tom holland
peter parker meaning that he's actually
talking to tobey maguire peter in that
scene and that this could just be
another example of deceptive trailer
editing but then this week andrew
garfield was asked by jimmy fallon about
a new photo that showed him on set with
tobey maguire we know what's up do you
know what's up
art
i had no idea
[Laughter]
have you seen the photo
what what are you talking about
yeah you wouldn't see the photo because
you're in the photo
no yeah it's not possible to see a photo
i heard about it
and i did see it and it's a photoshop
we say no
i'm trying to manage expectations now
the leak that jimmy valen was talking
about again your last chance to click
away here was a blurry set photo of what
looks like toby maguire and andrew
garfield together both suited up in
their respective era's spider-man suits
since then there is a new high
definition video of that showing andrew
garfield seemingly in the same position
it looks like he is asking you have web
blood to someone else in a spidey suit
presumably tony maguire peter parker
whose webbing unlike the other two
versions of peter we've seen spews out
organically from his wrists and then
andrew garfield looks over to the right
as if a third person like tom holland
peter is standing with them this seemed
to be what jimmy fallon was asking about
and what andrew garfield claimed was a
photoshop but then days after that a
youtube video from someone named alex
serrato titled how i trolled the entire
internet to andrew garfield deep fake
claims to have manufactured this footage
of garfield using archived footage of
his face from other tv interviews some
concluded from that that this could all
be a hoax the photoshop that andrew
garfield mentioned jimmy fallon but then
many more folks with actual vfx know-how
like some folks on the new rockstar
staff and youtubers like captain sting
have analyzed alex serrato's claim to
point out that serrato more likely
created his video by deconstructing
pieces of the original leak video
because when vfx artists create deep
fakes they need a stand-in body to map
the face onto and in this case it's
unclear where serato could have gotten
garfield's spider-man suited body at
this particular angle also in one of
serato's blue screen backgrounds that he
included in his video to suggest he
began with an empty clean plate if you
look at that closely it's not really the
cleanest photoshop job that he clearly
created by working backwards from that
original leak so it would now seem that
the debunker has been debunked with some
claiming the guy was just trolling i
know i know i know now if you like what
we do here at new rockstars and if you
like cool nerdy clothing and gear you
should head to newrockstarsmerch.com to
see what new stuff just dropped our
partners at epic hero shop have put
together a full lineup of really cool
gear shirts stickers hoodies all kinds
of cool items to grab for yourself or
give as a gift two of the newest items
in the shop are inspired by chongqi
there is a limited edition latest
obsession shirt the great protector as
well as the morris in the pocket shirt
with our favorite faceless furry mcu
character they're both super stylish
designs that will get you nods of
approval from other nerds whether you're
traversing a magical bamboo forest or
just strolling through the mall food
court they have a great what if inspired
shirt and a cool shirt based on
spider-man no way home that's only going
to be available for a short time there's
another shirt in the series tales from
the multiverse the mad son of krypton
with an awesome looking superman holding
the infinity gauntlet you can grab
yourself a new rockstars logo t-shirt or
baby onesie for that amazing hit baby in
your life check it all out at
newrockstarsmerch.com you'll be helping
out our channel while also earning major
nerd cred how did we get to this point
well to me what is weirdest about this
whole story is that in the past sony
usually forces youtube to remove any and
all content about leaks they don't want
this stuff being talked about but here
multiple uploads of that original
maybe maybe not leaked video are still
on youtube able to be watched and here's
what i can tell you personally from my
experience the tonight show the flagship
late night show of nbc comcast universal
was allowed to bring this up what in a
previous life i worked for several years
on a network talk show and you wouldn't
believe the clearance protocols these
productions are under all the time they
have to call other studios and
production companies asking for
permission to include footage or even
bring up certain news stories and the
reality you're probably aware of at this
point for most talk shows folks every
question the host asks is pre-approved
by the guests and their publicist in
pre-interviews before they even arrive
on set in most cases now that wasn't
always the case with hosts like david
letterman or craig ferguson but hostly
jimmy fallon almost never surprised
their guests with actual gotcha
questions like this as off-the-cuff and
playful as it seems it's pretty much all
planned out like look no further than
fallon's bit where he had maisie
williams accidentally spoil the game of
thrones finale just to reveal it was all
a prank so
what is going on well i do not trust
most of what folks have put out there as
evidence of toby and andrew's
involvement in no way home i believe
images and footage can be doctored and i
have played werewolf enough times to
know that giggly oversharing denials
usually prove nothing none of us are
close enough with andrew garfield for a
baseline of how he acts when he is lying
outside of this weird parasocial
relationship we all now have with the
poor guy i'm more interested in clues in
actual released footage and the fact
remains that spider-man no way home is a
multiverse story with characters from
the universes toby and andrew were part
of according to the logic this movie is
clearly operating under the door is wide
open for them to appear and i think at
the end of the day they will based on
these new rumors we're hearing about a
mind-blowing post-credit scene following
venom let there be carnage and
confirmations from director andy circus
that venom and spider-man will meet not
a matter of if but when it is clear that
sony's broader plan is to merge all of
its separate spider-man universes into
one shared with the mcu we know this but
i also find it interesting that andrew
garfield said i am trying to manage
expectations because when it comes to
the spider-man films sony has a track
record of trying to lean in on
expectation management with regards to
leaks after tom holland blurted out
secrets while promoting spider-man
homecoming sony has since made a joke
out of this by staging holland revealing
the title of the sequel far from home on
a tablet and then the title announcement
video for this movie no way home was a
similar bit about how tom holland can't
be trusted not to leak stuff so it would
not surprise me to learn that andrew
garfield might be being coached to
continue just laughing off and denying
this but at the same time the studio is
still allowing him to be asked this
question because their only play now is
to create doubt around these leaks so
that fans might throw up their hands and
say well who knows what to believe but
we know what to believe toby maguire and
andrew garfield will be in spider-man no
way home even if they never show up in
spider-man no way home because head
canon were placed on screen canon when
greedo shot first
this ain't new so enjoy this leaked look
of andrew garfield one way or another
for many this will be the true
spider-man no way home you can support
new rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you